[Music]
here in this video we are going to
showcase the top 20 biggest marvel
characters and creatures
which we will include the ones from the
marvel cinematic universe non-mcu
associated movies comics and other media
as well
so subscribe if you haven't and now
let's get down to business
number 20 chian tang
the impulsive qian tang is the brother
of the dragon king he is in fact a
hundred feet deadly flying dragon cian
tang can fly and breathe fire he can
also show immunity to age and while he
can be injured by sufficient power
he heals from virtually any wound via
mystic rights he has even recovered from
being decapitated
number 19 we have the chittari leviathan
the leviathans are cybernetically
augmented huge creatures around 100 to
200 feet long used for combat and troop
transport by the jittari armies under
thanos's control
leviathans are large creatures with
serpentine bodies and massive teeth they
are clad almost completely in armor
plating and that is outfitted with large
fin-like blades
at number 18 we have finn fang fume finn
fang fume is a mclawen a shape-shifting
alien being from the world of
kakaranthara also known as mark lufo in
the macular system of the greater
magellanic cloud he resembles a somewhat
anthropomorphic chinese dragon in the
battle with iron man he was at least as
tall as a skyscraper around 200 to maybe
400 feet tall
at number 17 we have emmer emmer is a
being of nifelheim one of the nine
realms he was the presenter and the most
powerful of the ice giants a race from
which the giants of jotunheim came to be
emer was covered with snow and ice and
can generate coldness from his body he
was at least a thousand feet tall
at number 16 we have goliath alight is a
trans-temporal entity that serves as the
guardian of the void created during the
multiversal war alliance exists across
divergent realities as an enormous cloud
destroying all it touches causing a
massive temporal disturbance and
devastation across entire dimensions in
the loki series it was anywhere between
a thousand to one thousand five hundred
feet tall
number fifteen dormammu dormammu is a
primordial interdimensional entity who
wields an apocalyptic level of
supernatural power and is the ruler of
the dark dimension and as the absolute
rule of the dark dimension domamu has
absolute control over it in doctor
strange the movie it was hard to assess
the size but by the looks of it he would
have been anywhere between a thousand to
two thousand feet tall
on the number 14 spot we have esson the
searcher a member of the ancient
primordial race known as the celestials
issan the searcher was one of the
previous owners of the power stone one
of the infinity stones
at some point of time isn't used the
power stone to level the surface of an
entire planet as seen during the events
of guardian of the galaxy's vol 1
vaporizing all life as a result the size
of the cosmic being was revealed to be
around 2000 feet tall
number 13 nezer the calculator seen in
eternals issue 9 nezel the calculator
was another member of the race of
celestials 2 000 feet tall and depicted
in dark blue armor nasa participated in
the celestial's four visits to earth as
a member of the fourth horse of the
celestials nazar appeared in the soviet
union and was targeted by an atomic
missile
number 12 arishim yet another celestial
on this list is a resham the judge first
seen in eternals issue 2 and now in the
mcu movie eternals erishim first came to
earth along with other several other
celestials in order to bring about the
beginning and the creation of the
seventh cosmos but then came into
conflict with the primordial god of
darkness null the father of the
symbiotes
at number 11 we have sirte serta was a
fire demon and a lord of masspelheim and
a significant figure in the prophecy of
ragnarok as the one who would initiate
the fall of asgard he was seen in thor
ragnarok the movie and was the cause of
asgard's destruction as well as the
death of heller and he was reunited with
the eternal flame and grew to be of
gigantic size around 500 to 1000 meters
or 1650 feet to 3280 feet tall
at number 10 we have nowhere
seen in guardians of the galaxy vol 1
nowhere is the seventh head of a
celestial that was killed in the ancient
past and hundreds of years ago the
tivian group set up mining operations
inside of it in order to harvest the
valuable bone brain tissue and spinal
fluid of the celestial just the head
alone it was one to two kilometers or
3200 to 6500 feet in size imagine the
entire being some say this was madonna
another celestial
at number nine we have the apocalypse
bees in the earth's ancient past a giant
egg leonard from space hatching a giant
creature which was to become known as
the apocalypse bees it was naturally
super strong to a phenomenal degree as
well as virtually indestructible and
because of its gigantic size standing at
15 000 feet or 4.5 kilometers tall
number 8 we have exeter exeter the
executioner is another celestial and the
largest one aside from ego of the planet
exeter's purpose was to destroy the life
on the worlds which failed the
celestial's deaths exodus power is
superior to galactus the in-betweener
and odin or zeus and can affect reality
on a universal scale he is stated to be
twenty thousand feet tall or six
kilometers
where did that indian accent come from
anyway number seven ego the living
planet ego was a celestial a primordial
and powerful being and the biological
father of peter quill a living planet
with a humanoid extension of himself ego
sought to find meaning in his life and
to achieve this end he planned to remake
the entire universe via an extinction
level event known as the expansion and
make it all as a part of himself he was
in the range of 3 000 kilometers around
the size of earth's moon
number six yeoman gander yeah we have
yeoman gander in marvel seen in thor
issued 127 of 1966 he is also called the
midgar serpent and was gigantic in
science nearly 5 earths long or 50 000
kilometers approximately the mid god
serpent usually existed in an ethereal
form on earth hence though his size was
so great that he encircled the planet he
was invisible and intangible as far as
human beings were concerned
at the number 5 spot we have galactus
galactus is the sole survivor of the
sixth incarnation of the multiverse
originally galactus was a humanoid named
galen born in the previous incarnation
of earth 616 in the previous universe on
a planet called tar a paradise like
world
then after that there have been many
incarnations of him and over the years
they have kind of varied in size but the
biggest one the largest version was at
least a hundred thousand kilometers in
size
number four jamiyah jamire in the comics
jamaiti analyzer functions as a
celestial
which analyzes the progression and
activities of the civilizations that
their celestials have conducted in their
genetic experiments
and report them back to the leader of
the celestial's host irishman the judge
jemiah was seen in the trailer of
eternals looking at a planet forming in
space and thus he was cosmic in size
probably more than a hundred thousand
kilometers stall
number three we have shimmer gorath
shimagurath is an ancient force of chaos
the immortal nigh invincible and godlike
ruler of nearly a thousand
maybe a hundred alternate universes
capable of energy projection
shape-shifting teleportation levitation
altering reality and sympathetic magic
among many other feats on earth when he
appeared he was small but on his own
home dimension he is larger than stars
number two the abstract entities the
abstract entities are a group of cosmic
beings that are of unknown origin and
nearly omnipotent in power these beings
include eternity infinity oblivion and
death being abstract in nature they do
not have a true physical form they can
be as small as microscopic or as large
as the universe itself they are often
depicted in cosmic scale and are as
large as large can be
and number one the living tribunal the
living tribunal was a vastly powered
humanoid cosmic entity who has existed
as long as the universe itself
it functions to save god from an
imbalance of mystical forces it acts to
prevent one universe from amassing power
more power than any of the others or
from upsetting the cosmic balance in
some way he can be infinite in size
and so with that we come to the end of
the video so do remember to hit that
like button for support and subscribe to
be a part of our mind cue family also
ring that bell button for regular
updates when we post new master content
right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam